ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show we have a mind-blowing
episode today this is literally one of
the most mind-blowing probably the most
mind-blowing podcast episode I've ever
done we have Whitney Webb on who's a
journalist she's written the best
articles about Jeffrey Epstein Glenn
Maxwell about the powers behind Epstein
she's also written a great article about
a lot of the companies that stand to
profit from introducing the solutions to
Cove at 19 she you know writes a lot
about Bill Gates and his relationship
with Epstein that's what she talks about
on this podcast we also play private
audio from a phone call a private phone
call that Whitney had with an Epstein
accuser a victim of Epstein Maria former
who the mainstream media has reported on
but of course the mainstream media did
not report everything Maria told them so
we had permission to play the phone call
we play clips from the phone call
Whitney breaks them down and analyzes
them some of them are incredibly
shocking very disturbing and then
Whitney goes on and talks about gates
and she talks about a lot of factions
within the United States government that
plan on copying the authoritarian model
that you see in China of how they've
structured their society there's this
idea that in order to compete with China
and still be the top of global hegemony
we need to adopt a lot of the things
that China has done successfully
including trampling human rights
including moving everything to a
cashless driverless society eliminating
the ownership of private vehicles I mean
it's really crazy when she talks about
this document that came out from a
Freedom of Information request about how
a lot of people in the government plan
to use the the economic shutdown and the
pandemic to usher in a lot of new rules
regulations surveillance systems things
like that
Whitney's great her work is always very
well researched she's not a hysteric
she's somebody who stands behind
everything she says and it's an honor to
have her here she writes at the last
American vagabond that's also a YouTube
channel she also has a patreon that you
could support her work and the link will
be in the description she has a book
coming
out about Jeffrey Epstein so this is
about an hour and fifteen minute
conversation again it a lot of what goes
on here is [ __ ] unbelievable so again
is you know there's a few jokes it's not
overall a very funny episode but you
know every now and then we do an episode
like this to really keep you up at night
and this will absolutely 100% do that if
you're not up at night already which you
should be alright everybody we've got
Whitney Webb she's one of our favorites
one of the best journalists in America
that doesn't live here that's why she's
better she's written some great articles
she's written the best articles about
Jeffrey Epstein she's written a great
article in the last American vagabond
right is that yeah that's the site and
it's about Bill Gates and it's about all
the companies that stand to profit from
all of the different solutions to
coronavirus and she's always doing a lot
of research and work and then putting
out these very long really detailed well
researched articles on very difficult
topics that a lot of people don't go
into so we're very excited to have you
thanks for coming on this show and and I
spoke to you this morning and you said
you you and we're gonna go into gates
and stuff cuz I you know obviously a lot
of people saw me and Rogan kind of did
that little we had a little a little fun
argument about Bill Gates who I don't
know anything about other than I've read
some articles about him and I you know
the Rogan was like well bill doesn't
have any reason you know he does he has
enough money he doesn't want any more
money but as you know whether it's
George Soros or the Koch brothers or
Bill Gates billionaires often engage in
in social engineering they have an
ideology they want to impact the world
some of it is good a lot of it isn't so
I you know what's interesting is like
we're gonna all have to understand what
Bill Gates and and a lot of these people
are are trying to do it should be
transparent and that was my my thing
with Joe I was just basically like
listen we all want to solve
climate change but if I said to you part
of that was having a one child per
family policy and you could never drive
an SUV and we're gonna put a cap on you
know the energy that you could consume
you might say wait a minute whoa whoa
hold on so we all agree nobody wants
coronavirus nobody wants you know
everybody wants some way to prevent
coronavirus but it's the details which
is something that you're very good at
it's figuring out what the details are
of these solutions quickly cuz then
we're going to go into this epstein
thing but quickly just blanket off the
bat with gates what concerns you
particularly about Bill Gates and some
of the initiatives that he's pushed
around the world
all right so Oh Bill Gates is one of
those billionaires who had a ton of
money and it took him a really long time
to get involved in philanthropy but not
just speaking about Bill Gates but
so-called philanthropists in general
since the day of the very first
billionaire in the United States john d
rockefeller they have tried to rebrand
themselves as philanthropists even
Jeffrey Epstein before he was arrested
the first time used to be called
philanthropist it's been used a lot of
times to basically launder a person's
reputation when they get involved in odd
or unsavory you know unsavory activities
which billionaires you know we've seen
over the years sometimes they're prone
to do right so as far as Gates goes you
know a lot of people have compared his
foundation the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation to the Rockefeller Foundation
sort of as a like the successor to that
even though that foundation still exists
in a lot of ways focusing a lot of
attention on developing countries and
some of those those things that have
happened and you know scandals with the
vaccines and all that with Bill Gates
has to do with the fact that his
foundation has a lot of close ties to
major pharmaceutical giants and in some
cases some of those vaccines that were
originally rejected for use in the
United States ended up being sent abroad
to other countries developing countries
like India for example on where they
ended up having really severe health
effects and the you know largely the
girls that received them yeah and a lot
of other country
versus I mean vaccines in general
there's some you know a lot of people
get really agitated when people bring up
vaccines but it's important to remember
that you know there can be some vaccines
that are produced poorly or produced for
example in a facility that is not up to
standards and has sanitary issues for
example and then when those vaccines are
used that can cause adverse reactions
and that is you know a crime essentially
and and wrong and there can be people
that can talk about pharmaceutical
corruption and not necessarily be
against vaccines as a science what we
see a lot of times is this conflation of
people saying oh you're criticizing this
particular vaccine or this particular
pharmaceutical company or this
particular vaccine manufacturer you must
be against all vaccines i don't think
that's true at all
but in terms of Bill Gates one thing I
do want to point out about him is that
his rhetoric over the years has been
very odd when it has to when it comes to
vaccines he said you know stuff at these
TED talks like we can you know bring
down the world population by you know
for good on vaccines and stuff like that
and that's kind of odd right on
presumably vaccines exist to keep people
alive longer not to reduce population so
the fact that he's talking about it that
way um I think is it's reasonable that
people are concerned about that
especially considering too that he's
talked about for years that he's
concerned that the global population is
too large
specifically in Africa a few years ago
he was saying that he was very concerned
and bothered by how many the African
youth boom is is the term used in the
report there and I just don't really
understand what we have to be putting
you know trotting out this billionaire
on CNN and stuff telling us how to
respond to this this crisis when he
doesn't have a medical degree he's a
he's a guy that didn't even finish
university he dropped out of Harvard and
then went on and became this you know
tech guy you know massive tech
billionaire because he got this deal
with IBM and the 80s and all this stuff
right but why is he giving medical
advice on a massive scale I mean it just
seems really odd but the thing you know
to me that's the biggest red flag about
Gates is his relationship with Epstein
and I say this for a couple of reasons
mainly that if you look at who was the
one of the executors on Epstein's well
it was a guy named Boris Nicholas who
was actually Bill Gates chief scientist
advisor there's pictures of Nicolette
gates and an Epstein also Larry Summers
you know all together piling around and
it came out you know after last year
after the the second Epstein arrest last
year that Epstein was very interested in
eugenics right I mean this was openly
admitted in mainstream media media and
what I was told what we're gonna get
into you today about Epstein by by one
of his victims is that they talked about
eugenics all the time and talked about
the superiority of races and and how
other races are lesser than others and
she was like this is how these people
think they talked to me like this they
told me I was lesser than them you know
because I didn't have their DNA how
close our gates and Epstein personally
well so there has been a huge cover-up
on gates and Epstein ties I can say that
for a fact because the New York Times
originally it said like they had met in
2016 and then the New York Times said oh
no actually it was 2011 but that's a lie
and I know this because there is this
article that is they've tried to scrub
from the internet but you can still find
it if you're you know persistent like I
am on it's from The Evening Standard a
UK newspaper it's from January 2001 it
was written by Nigel Rosser and in there
it talks about a whole bunch of stuff
about Epstein of course this was before
he was controversial controversial right
so it says a lot of things about Epstein
it even mentions the intelligence ties
it says CIA it says Mossad in this
article right but other white sentence
that really caught my attention was
Jeffrey Epstein made his you know his
millions all his money from his business
links to these three men and it says
those three men are Leslie Wexner Donald
Trump and the third one is Bill Gates
and this isn't 2001 and so obviously
there had to have been some relationship
there right right this 2001 so this is
an article written in 2001 about a had
why was it written was it like just a
piece about Jeffrey Epstein it was some
type of just biography or what what
exactly what was a tone of the article
so in this period of time Epstein had
gotten some media attention mainly
because he was being or he was a scene
around Prince Andrew a lot in public
during this period
of time and ghilane Maxwell had always
sort of generated interest and the
British press because her father was
like this hated white-collar criminal
basically because he you know raided
that pension fund of you know the The
Daily Mirror and all this stuff so she
had sort of pop up in tabloid coverage
throughout the 1990s and this article
was focusing on on d'Alene and Epstein's
relationship with with Andrew and was
trying to say to the British public you
know who were these you know new pals of
pals of Andrew Prince Andrew that we're
seeing you know hearing about all the
time who are they really and trying to
find out something about them before
anyone had really tried to do much of a
deep dive on them right and so that's
where this article came from and it
talks about Bill Gates openly and the
first epstein victim to go to the FBI
I'm Maria farmer who I interviewed
yesterday she said that when she was
around she was around Epstein and and
ghilane pretty much every day for like
two years and she said that she heard
them talk about Bill Gates in 1995 like
they knew him really well we're gonna
get into that interview because that's
very interesting but just in general
after looking into this information is
it your belief that it's very possible
if not probable or likely that somebody
like Bill Gates has very different views
in private than the ones he shared in
public oh yeah okay absolutely I think
all of these billionaires do I mean
let's think about Leslie Wexler for
example if you're going to buy the
reasoning that well he has so much money
he doesn't need anything else I mean why
would he do anything bad right um a lot
of times there's these people like this
that get this type of money anyone they
can't buy anything else they want
control right yes they want they want
that they're about you know that like
you said social engineering and control
or you know sort of imposing their
vision of the world and what they think
is best on other people or telling
everyone else to make sacrifices that
they will never have to make I mean
that's another big thing trying for you
yeah basically engineer the lives of
regular people and and tell them to make
sacrifices where you know the wealthy
and the government will never be forced
to make those types of sacrifices well
with Bill Gates and vaccines why did his
you
the the pediatrician for his children
come forward and say that Bill Gates
refused to have his children vaccinated
is that true
from what I understand yes Wow
that's very interesting because
obviously it's you know who wants Bill
Gates you know on your bad side well we
we do we do right here I've said that
before come and get us I'm kidding we i
or am i but let's get into this
interview with maria farmer who's
Epstein's an Epstein victim she's
somebody that you interviewed or spoke
to on the phone for three and a half
hours and she reached out to you because
she was upset about a ruling that came
down talk a little bit about this ruling
that a lot of people don't understand
the significance of it eventually clear
it essentially closes the door on
anybody paying any price for what
happened to those women yeah you know in
a nutshell not to get too technical on
anyone basically what it means is that
someone like d'Alene Maxwell or any
other co-conspirator and what Epstein
was involved in walks free and they walk
free for good it's basically saying
these people are immune to prosecution
and attend any epstein victim that comes
forward and tries to say this person was
involved they can't go to court and that
ruling came down and it was basically I
think separating civil and criminal
trials was it something like that
there's so many different cases right
now so I'm not a hundred percent sure on
that but I mean the important takeaway
is that essentially it claims that these
other you know the sweetheart deal as
it's called all right oh she it was done
that that stands it was done correctly
you know and part of that deal that he
got the first time was that none of his
co-conspirators had to be named like
gray Maxwell or they're immune so they
all got immunity so when Epstein's first
deal was given out by a judge in Florida
and it was negotiated by a believe
Acosta who's the Secretary of Labor he
negotiated that deal for
epsteen epsteen part of it was that none
of his co-conspirators would ever have
to face prosecution that seems insane
that you would be putting getting
blanket immunity to all his
co-conspirators but then that was the
ruling that was held up recently
so that Colin Maxwell so tell us a
little bit about Maria farmer and how
you guys started talking um well she
actually contacted me a while ago and I
had just been really busy and was not I
was working on other stuff not epstein
research just because of like the crazy
times we live in there's so much going
on right but then this really happened
and I was like you know what let's talk
right now you know I you you your guys's
voice matters we need I mean the ruling
to me is just so outrageous because it
just sends this horrible message that
people can get away with crimes on this
scale to kids you know and and nothing
happens to them as long as they're in
bed with intelligence or organized crime
or the right you know billionaires you
have enough money I mean you can do
anything you want basically that is the
takeaway that certainly is the takeaway
you know right so it's infuriating
and I was like you know that was a good
time and so I'm I had originally planned
to just ask her about the ruling and she
told me you know um she had talked to so
many reporters in mainstream media I
mean pretty much every outlet you can
think of and they just would not tell
her story she said as soon as I every
time I would bring up Wexler they never
they always cut it out and she told me
wetters the head of the snake is what
she said she said of this whole
operation he's the head of the snake
you know he's the guy he's the brains of
this he's the guy that's coordinating
this all from his you know mansions this
is just the guy in charge basically and
essentially you know yeah and I mean
other people have said this the UFC was
basically just like a project manager he
was like mid-level management in terms
of this scheme you know people say oh
yeah well he's gone so I mean that must
mean this stopped no way rile the people
that are at the top that were doing this
you know Epstein was just he was there
because he was really charismatic he
could convince these girls that he was
going to make their lives better
you know he was apparently really
charming and able to like you know bring
them in and then once they're in I mean
you just the tactics these people use I
mean make sure media doesn't really
report on that either you know like they
wouldn't let them they'd have the call
to permit for permission to go outside
they're all these pinhole cameras
everywhere they watch their every move
even watch them like undress to change
clothes and stuff you know I mean once
you're in there it's really hard to get
out red and so any what were some of the
more you know when she called you what
were some of the things that other than
then Wexner what were some of the other
things that she had told you that
specifically mainstream media would not
allow her to say or would cut out well
it was specifically anything to do with
Wexner um in a lot of other thing I mean
it was just so much because you know I
had read about her story in mainstream
media cuz they've reported on her right
and honestly she said everything that
she had told me she had told them and
less than five percent ended up in
mainstream media are you I mean are you
of the opinion that Wexner has it is an
asset of either a foreign intelligence
service or our intelligence service she
said that he he worried that he's Mossad
that's what she said right it does and
then actually he's part of the the mob
like the the Mafia it was like organized
its organized crime and you know in my
series I point that out too that he you
know has basically documented ties to
the national crime syndicate which is
the Jewish and Italian mafia they
started their Union in the 1920s and
they've pretty much been blackmailing
ever since and they got in bed with this
you know the OSS the precursor the CIA
and then after the CIA was made they got
in bed with them and that's where all of
this has really come from right so
waxers you know a part of that and he's
been carrying the sign and but every
time she would bring him up they would
cut it out they don't want to go after
Wexner but you know I mean if he's the
head of this it won't stop until there's
some accountability for him but
apparently because he's the richest man
in Ohio no one wants to say anything and
I think that's sick what he has a yeah
Apple absolutely what did she say about
ghilane Maxwell what was her role in
this and where does she think she is
or well she said ghilane maxwell is the
most dangerous woman she thinks she's
ever met and the most dangerous asset
for israel that's a direct quote she
said that and she said that ghilane
maxwell talked about israel and said
that she that she and waxer and Epstein
were not loyal to the United States they
were loyal to Israel I mean she they
straight up told her that she had
passports ghilane did for like five
different countries including Israel
United States United Kingdom France um
you know I mean this woman was was
balls-deep in intelligence and of course
anyone that looks at her father knows
this ghilane also told her that she
believes her father was murdered by his
Raley intelligence but then given a
state funeral because of his importance
right among other things but she said
ghilane is is a dangerous very dangerous
woman but didn't have a lot of friends
so the people she would treat us you
know her servants her employees she
ended up trying to like share
information about herself she's like
have her go shopping with her sit her
down and go through photo albums of her
childhood um she got 12 photo albums of
her growing up with the royal family
that has not been mentioned in
mainstream media they claim the prince
and root eyes were like in the late 90s
with d'Alene Maxwell she says no way I
mean they were really young in these
pictures and her were like photo album
after photo album Wow of them yeah when
you say dangerous woman is it farmers
like that that ghilane could make people
disappear that she could I mean is
farmer did farmers suggest that like you
know there were certain girls or victims
that she used to see around that she
doesn't see around anymore
was there anything of that nature
discussed well on the last point she
didn't say ghilane she didn't talk about
killing murdering anyone per se but she
definitely does think that there were a
lot of kids that ended up dying that got
recruited we can go into that later but
in terms of what ghilane Maxwell was
doing you know she said that she
one day went to her art portfolio
because she wasn't she was recruited to
work for Epstein she was basically
forced to work for Epstein because of
the the Dean of the school the art
school she was going to New York
basically said oh you're gonna work for
you know these guys basically and that's
why she was there to watch more
portfolio I mean no I said what school
school not that's called York Academy of
Art and the woman that was the be the
the head of the school at the time was a
woman named Eileen Guggenheim and
there's pictures of her with this lady
Marina Abramovic
depends right why on the podcast I do
want to say that myself neither you or
suicidal no okay just want to let
everyone know that these people to town
yeah I mean yeah because the fact that
mainstream media would not report this
and it's fine it's my job now yeah the
FBI knew this all this stuff in 1996
Jesus most of mainstream media knew this
in the early 2000s Micky Ward knew all
this stuff so so the Guggenheim owned
school of Manhattan or she's the
principal or somebody tells Maria that
you are now gonna work for Jeffrey
Epstein basically yeah and and as what
as an assistant as a masseuse as uh I
mean she ended up doing like interior
decorating
okay stuff like that for all these
apartments because they had this whole
apartment building that's officially
owned by Epstein's brother we're like
all these girls were kept there were so
many places there were so many buildings
these apartments offices were Epstein
worked ghilane had offices I mean just
tons of real estate how many women are
we talking about girls at any given time
uh Murray this was a 1995 to 1996 she
said that she saw between at least five
different girls a day come in and out of
Epstein's offices okay so he's running a
global operation yes um we can I have
some audio clips yes from the class
- yeah let's let's get into that yeah
now you've heard you've heard a lot of
mind-blowing stuff but you you said this
call you were on was one of the most
mind-blowing things you've ever heard
yeah yeah this case I reported on it
like all last year I thought I knew what
had happened I just can't believe that
no one told the these women's stories
that they like limited hang out hang out
in the crap out of it
I just I'm appalled you know I I don't
like mainstream media that's why I do
what I do because they're not doing
their job you know but I didn't really
like hate them until this call
interesting all right let's get into the
first clip here that is a clip from the
call with you and Maria former Epstein
victim Whitney I got it I've got to tell
you something this is why I've been
dying to tell you there are only 30
women that have come forward 30 Whitney
I saw between I'm not kidding I'm very
disturbed by this part I saw at least
five girls come in that house a day I
mean I'm a really slow down no Whitney
it's in it's in the thousands where are
they where are they never they dead I
mean children not to be dead because
here's the thing like Brad was like what
if they speak a drug addict
what you think some of them were killed
I think that they had to be because
here's the thing Whitney Brad said he
knows that 500 just in Florida like we
can't find them where are they and the
thing is like oh this kids making his
loud machine out there anyway all I was
gonna say is that that these children
were between you know yeah thousand
thousand I was there a year and I saw
sevensupergirls which is it was so
exhausting Whitney they were in his
office
they were in there just constantly
little girls there constantly and I
remember one one of the reasons I quit I
said I am tired of dealing with the
number of people
cutting going you know I'm just tired of
and that sounds horrible now but I
didn't understand what was happening
entirely I just knew it was weird and I
certainly didn't know it was pedophilia
I mean and the other thing is G LAN had
said one day in Florida when I was in
Florida she said you know we have to go
on a jog for a while and I said why and
she said well Jeffrey needs three
massages so while I was in Florida there
were three little girls being assaulted
and now I look back on that I'm so
creeped out you know I didn't know but I
knew that they abused their maids from
the Philippines that was another reason
I quit because one day I went to take a
nap upstairs in the 66 in the mansion on
71st and you know I worked the door like
signing people in and there was no one
coming in that day and so I went and
took a nap and what they were the
sweetest ladies from the Philippines
ever and they came in and they were
looking at tucking me in and one of them
whispered we I said I said how long have
you worked here and she said we were
stolen like what does that mean they
were stolen they were trafficked and
they had them and they had women from
the Philippines in Florida and and in
New York and in the house on and the
ranch and no one ever cares like I
mentioned this and everybody goes yeah
well they traffic throughout the
Philippines and Thailand a serpent yeah
I mean that is so incredibly disturbing
to listen to the idea yeah the idea of
that that the mainstream media wouldn't
report that there were so many more
potential victims and there's been very
little effort on the part of the media
to find these women you know well those
500 victims in Florida they have their
names they can't find them anywhere
really who's got their names
the one of the victims lawyers and they
can not they know there's these 500
victims in Florida they can't find and
how did they get the names of those
victims I think you'd have to ask them I
don't really know exactly how they but I
mean you know it's their job than best
to eat this stuff and have houris
victims that have come forward yeah I
mean they apparently have names and
they're these girls are nowhere and
that's just 500 like she was saying this
was in the 90s this was like five a day
different girls yeah back then you could
make people disappear relatively easily
especially if they were from a lower
socioeconomic background some of them
were foster kids some of them were you
know fall through the cracks and and so
easily nobody's looking for those girls
nobody's trying to find them it's insane
now Maria farmer was a victim of Epstein
how was she sexually assaulted by him or
what what was her role there so she
started out as an interior decorator
then how does she get how does she get
wrapped up in in what else was going on
let me tell you I'll try and summarize
her story and and when you hear it you
will realize why the mainstream media
will not tell her story because it
happened the worst of it happened at
Westerners house okay in New Albany Ohio
right so obviously if they were to talk
about it in any sort of detail they can
talk about Wexler right right so at some
point where she was working for Epstein
she was basically told oh a beguile
wetzler that's leslie wepner's wife
wants an artist-in-residence and she was
basically you know told it would be
great and she could go eat at this
country club and go play tennis there
and it was gonna be all nice and I was
his biggest aide and there were horses I
don't know so she ends up going she
stays in his guest house it has just
like all these other residences all
these cameras everywhere they watch her
every move she has to call Abigail
Wexner or someone to get you know
permission to leave the house you can go
outside and like sit on the porch you
know um this Country Club she tried to
go and she was told that she wouldn't be
served which interesting what just weird
but apparently she said all these people
like d'Alene
all these people would just tell her
they were like really supremacists um I
don't know so apparently she said that
didn't surprise her based on everything
else she experienced around these people
but at some point you know she was there
for three months and they really limited
the amount of food they gave her she
felt like she was being starved she said
which is disturbing so she was basically
trapped there
you know um and you know Epstein and
Elaine came I think three to four times
during her three-month stay there on the
last stay they tried to rape her both of
them and Epstein and what what happened
then well I'm so when we talked she
jumped around a lot from different
topics from this to that from what I
understand after that you know they
ended up believing she called the police
and the police basically said they
weren't gonna come help her because they
work for Wexner they work at his gate at
the estate and to like stop calling
basically and how old was she when this
was happening she was an adult but I
don't know how the thing is she was an
adult when this happened but they took
her sister they kidnapped her sister and
she was like 15
when did there's something hidden that
her sister um I'd have to look because
it's a long story
I mean three and a half hours no of
course yesterday yeah but I mean
mainstream media the New York Times
basically makes the story son like oh
she went to Wexler's house to paint a
mural and Epstein hired her then Epstein
tried to put his hands on her and then
she called the cops and you know that
was it
no and apparently at some point this
bodyguard for Wexner who's former like
Special Forces military guy who's now
Will Smith's bodyguard um he basically
came over and was like you know you're
never leaving here and was like
basically like I'm gonna kill you and
the only reason she said she made it out
is because there was a landline in that
house and she called literally everyone
she had ever met in her entire life
Wow her entire like her whole family
as many people as she could saying
they're trying to kill me now because
they saw her making a stink with all
these cameras they ended up letting her
go and she said to me I was an adult at
the time what if I had been one of those
preteen girls or one of those younger
kids what would have happened to me
did she ever see any notable people any
bold-faced names with Epstein and
ghilane that would be surprising to
anybody oh yeah one thing that shocked
me honestly is that she said that in New
York ghilane would go to these like
around the time school would get out
like middle schools she would like drive
around and say that she was recruiting
models for Victoria's Secret and would
go up to like all these twelve-year-old
girls with like braces and stuff and
school uniforms but she almost always
went to do this with Ivana Trump Trump's
ex-wife and say they living together all
the time and this going around in cars
talking to these young girls and that
they would exchange information and the
next day those girls would be in
Epstein's office so she would go around
- I imagine you know where these prep
schools are these public I mean I don't
know exactly yeah it's hard to imagine
that they're going to very wealthy
schools because then the parents of
those kids would also be sort of
powerful and connected people but I but
who knows who knows but so she was going
to junior high schools middle schools
with Ivana Trump and getting and saying
she was recruiting girls for Victoria
wait what was even good fruit and girls
for she talked ghilane told Maria
because Maria would come along in the
car they'd be like come with us like
she's like d'Alene would take her
shopping and all this stuff she'd be
like get in the car let's go you know
she would like stay in the car and like
see these exchanges happen you know but
one thing she did tell me is that they
asked the kids about their grades they
only wanted the kids with good grades
they wanted smart kids and they wanted
talented kid
like creative kids and she would send a
modeling agency and then and you do this
with Ivana Trump yeah I mean it's
satanic it's horrible it's evil
what vana Trump what's what's the angle
there I mean I mean does does her name
come up yeah never come up before but
she was like I want her to explain
herself why would she always there and
why was she always going around with
ghilane with these kids you know why was
she involved like she should explain
herself that's what that's what Maria is
there are a lot of photos with ghilane
and Ivana Trump I haven't seen any but
that doesn't mean I would yeah okay I
mean there's pictures of ghilane and
Trump from like the early 90s and stuff
so I really honestly want it be this
surprising this was like mid 90s right
this is like 95 all right you know by
the time it hit like 2000 and so like
the Trump epstein relationship sort of
started to get rocky it started to
degenerate why why exactly did it start
to get rocky well from what I understand
it was sort of competition about real
estate at some point there was this
mansion in Palm Beach that FC wanted to
buy and flip and then and then he shut
it to Trump and asked his opinion and
then Trump ended up taking it from
Epstein or something like that some sort
of like real estate marksmanship games
yeah apparently after Trump did that the
epsteen epsteen tried to like set him up
or something with some sort of like
blackmail saying I don't so Maria when
did Maria start figuring out that hey
this is not a modeling agency it's not
that these aren't talents Kouts these
people are pedophiles did she figure it
out before she got was it the rape in
Ohio that did it the attempted rape or
she had no she said yes okay during the
attempted rape she was like she said
everything like that started to click
all this weird stuff she'd seen and just
like didn't understand just thought they
were like just weird total weirdos she
when she was being assaulted it just
clicked she's like these people have
been around my sister you know he's way
younger than her right right these
people burned on my sister and then she
said that she out of nowhere had this
feeling that they've taken these
pictures she had of her of her sisters
that were like hidden and like the
basement of this guesthouse she like had
all her stuff there like super organized
and because she was an artist she had
like some pictures of like her younger
sisters like half naked for like Anatomy
stuff but she always painted them with
their clothes on and apparently they had
gone in there and taken the pictures and
after she escaped that mass barely she
called Epstein's office trying to get
those pictures back and eventually
someone called her back and said don't
try and get the pictures back there in
his briefcase and he's using them and
then she hung up how long did you work
for him in total it was nine 1995 to
1996 when that you know when she was
assaulted I don't know exactly what
month she began I I had to do a
follow-up call with her it was just
taking it all in at once you know I mean
yeah I was just like tell me whatever
you want to tell me you know it's like I
have all afternoon
let's go what else did you see anything
yeah what else do you remember in terms
of disturbing or you know things that
you would not necessarily heard before
well there's a clip for this one yeah
she said the FBI is was just as abusive
to her as as I've seen in Maxwell which
is just insane since that's supposed to
be the institution that protects people
like this
yeah let's I mean well who believed
nobody listening to this show believes
that I'll say it I'm sure there are
people out there that believe that
nobody's listening to this show okay
what let's play that clip because that's
an interesting clip to get into today's
after she left was that the end of
contact she had with them after the
assault and they finally let her out
what did she have any further contact
with them yeah yeah she said that when
she went back to New York after that
whole incident in Ohio the Epstein's
doctor and followed her around very
creepy alright we're gonna play the clip
now here's the FBI clip I mean okay I
can't even explain to you how abusive
the effing bee is it's unbelievable to
me I mean they first of all never
offered me witness protection and when I
first called them they knew I was don't
believe me they knew I would out they
knew everything I was telling him they
already knew because they're in on it
and it was so weird his reactions
I was talking to him you know I called
and I got some answer guy and then he
passes me to some guy who's like when I
start talking about Wexner you know and
I asked the guy do you have this is all
over the thumb in 1996 I said do you
have a file unless Wexner and he said
why and I said he's the head of the
snake in this in America and I don't
even know I was intuiting this just and
also I think it's common sense when you
see all the stuff of all going on and
anyway when I said that to him he said
yeah but I don't know maybe we do and I
said well he's a he's these people are
using child pornography and they've
stolen photographs of my sisters vadik
that right there would have been life in
prison for Jeff Randall and I still have
the envelope with their touch DNA and
fingerprints on them and the FBI will
not take them from me they never would
they would never take the envelopes that
they stole I mean they photographs out
of these envelopes and I have proof I
still have the envelopes Whitney and the
FBI was like yeah no we don't we don't
need that they also knew in 1996 that I
had been trafficked and Annie had been
trafficked and that would have been
enough to put them away but they never
cared they didn't care and the worst
part was I lamed everybody I named
Donald Trump I named everyone who I
thought was a co-conspirator at the time
so I named like Alan Dershowitz Donald
Trump absolutely the Clintons you know
these are people that I saw coming and
going that I knew were part of it and I
made it really clear that this is a very
scary thing for children and that I see
between five and ten girls a day going
upstairs and now that I know what
happening to them I want it stopped and
that's supposed to go yeah I mean this
is just mind-blowing stuff you know when
she says that she tells the FBI that you
know she has information on on people
that are trafficking children and they
do nothing and we've heard this before
we've heard it with the Franklin scandal
there's been many other pedophile rings
in the UK
Quorra boys home in the UK north Fox
Island another another much smaller but
also wealthy powerful people abused you
children
the Franklin scandal is the big you know
from the 80s and 90s is the huge
precursor to Epstein um where you had a
very politically connected figure doing
the same exact thing what is your belief
when you zoom out for a minute and you
look at this from 30,000 feet and what
does this say about our society what
does it say about the ruling class what
does it say about elites what does it
say about how people are controlled what
what does it say to you after looking at
all this stuff
what can you what can you extract from
this and apply it to like kind of
overarching thesis of of what's going on
that we don't really know about oh wow
okay so this is definitely global in
scale number one I think a lot of these
elites aren't loyal to the nation's they
live in they're loyal to their ruling
class like this is a supranational like
swamp basically you know how people in
the US are calling like you know the the
deep state the swamp I mean I feel like
you know there's a lot of billionaires
that have this sort of super national
structure and they're just like in it to
do this sick stuff because Leslie Wexner
is not the only billionaire that's into
this right I can say that perfect well
yeah when we hear people talk about the
occult and that a lot of these people
are just into strange weird ancient
religions and weird types of ceremonies
and things like that
how much does that figure into some of
the things that you've looked at whether
it's Marina Abramovic or what cuz I
dismiss a lot of that stuff because I
say it's bad enough if they're
pedophiles I don't really care if
they're satanic or Mormon it doesn't
really matter that much to me
how much credence do you put in this
stuff where you do see a lot of a cult
imagery and a lot of a cult types of
ceremonies in these you know whether
it's secret societies or fraternity I
mean
what amount of weight do you give that
stuff well you know I think throughout
the time like several decades have there
been a lot of people looking at the
stuff I think intelligence agencies have
had people out there to do what they
call muddy the waters you know trying
discredit legitimate research and into
these type of crimes by putting out
stuff that's just like you know not but
in terms of like the you know the Satan
is stuff and all of that actually I
didn't take any clips out from this but
Maria did said that she saw weird
symbols at like Epstein's places and
Elaine's apartment and stuff that she
saw somewhere else later word and
someone told her that like that was
Buffett yeah like a Satanist thing like
she saw she said she saw that but wasn't
like overly familiar with that type of
stuff
it was taste it was tasteful it wasn't
overdone the bottom a successful it was
it wasn't overdone it was a little
little batiment there a little yeah um
what when people talk about the Clintons
and Trump you know we're talking about
the most being a powerful people but see
they're not the most powerful people in
the world but they're certainly you know
they occupy some of those powerful
positions in the world when you when you
what is your opinion of the role that
either one of those men had in this
after looking at a lot of the
information that you've looked at well
honestly I think since the days of John
F Kennedy the president doesn't really
have as much power as we'd like to think
he does I think part of the reason for
that is to make people think that
elections like actually make a
difference at least presidential
elections and that is law and have
people you know sort of develop this
political savior complex as long as we
have the right guy in the White House
you know then every as long as you know
we can fix things if we get this one guy
in this one office and I think since the
days of JFK that type of stuff is not
really reasonable anymore because what
we're dealing with is you know these
intelligence agencies that do these
things like you know support Epstein in
in that type of activity for example but
they're also involved in drug running
they're also involved involved in gun
running I mean they're essentially
organized crime syndicates so I'm like I
said earlier they got in bed the CIA
right as soon as it was formed basically
got in bed with the mob and they're in
bed with the mob and a bunch of other
countries they work closely with other
intelligence agencies like Mossad and
mi5 in the UK that do the same thing so
um yeah I mean that's basically who
rules the world but they answer to
people - right and that's actually um
there's this one clip that I that I have
to conclude I guess that we're good
lanes talking about a little bit because
she says that even though ghilane and
and Waxman we're working for Israel
right so she said Wexner was the head of
the snake in America but there's another
family that she thinks is like the head
of the snake snake okay and and and
where does she think Elaine Maxwell is
currently bad sigh let's play the clip
all right here Maria farmer Epstein
victim is talking about ghilane Maxwell
so then she says to me you know my dad
was a very powerful man and you know he
was very important she said Maria you
don't understand the man she's showing
me like who she grew up with and how
powerful he was and how much money they
had and then she goes on to tell me she
said you know Maria and this is true she
said and she showed me she had Passport
get this I don't know how this is legal
she had a passport rented passports an
English passport an Israeli passport an
American passport and there was one
other I'm trying to think of what the
other one was and I was like I thought
you were only allowed to be citizen like
of two countries or something I didn't
know she's like oh no no no because of
my dad I'm the citizen of all these
nations and I'm like what
so then later when she was talking to me
about something one day she said that
the Rothschilds were the greatest
protectors of her family and she wasn't
talking about Lindh Forester by the way
she's the people that are in her okay so
the Rothschilds who are the Ross because
that's like their the centerpiece of
every conspiracy since beginning of time
pretty much
who are they I mean I kind of as soon as
I hear the rothschilds I usually roll my
eyes and go ah boy here we go then
people are gonna start talking about
numerology soon and you know like you're
gonna get into like so who are the
Roth's I mean I who are the Rothschilds
other than a very they're a
multi-generational banking family I mean
I don't want to like talk about all the
different things people have said about
them over the years but there are some
obvious facts people who can point to a
multi-generational banking family in
several countries in Europe you know a
lot of very influential people that
later we go into positions of major
political power and sometimes they're
Rothschild bankers like macaron of
France used to work for a Rothschild
bank Commerce Secretary of the United
States Wilbur Ross also used to work for
them right um but it's also worth
pointing out since you know we it's
pretty much documented now that these
guys were working with Israeli
intelligence that the influence of the
Rothschilds in the creation of Israel I
mean this is historical fact the Balfour
Declaration that really paved the way
for the creation of Israel as a
political state was addressed to the
Rothschild family I mean they were the
people that really pushed you know
funded and nurtured the Zionist movement
in its early days in the 19th century
and I mean you can see that reflected in
Israel today one of the biggest roads in
Tel Aviv is named after a Rothschild the
Knesset building which is like Israel's
Congress I mean that was financed by the
Rothschild family they have definite
influence there I would argue and I
think a lot of other people I mean it's
hard to see that type of money floating
around and patronage to a certain
nation-state and assume they don't have
the influence there and right and
Elaine's father was an Israeli asset
intelligence asset and a media mogul
right he published papers and that you
can in the UK right right okay so he was
you know probably the proper propaganda
arm okay Mack Robert Maxwell did like he
had a relationship with with Russian
intelligence as well but he apparently
British intelligence thought about
recruiting him at some point and they
said no because he's only loyal to
Israel so he was considered to be like
you know and as
really superspy basically but he had
like a lot of connections to different
intelligence agencies in the world but
apparently he had been given money to
build his media empire by massage
penance ears are fine answers and and
had basically been on you know put in
this position to manage this money and
he didn't you know it wasn't able to pay
him Assad back at some point and started
making threats and when Epstein gets
caught the second time is this just a
major glitch in the matrix is this that
nobody see this coming whoa how does you
know he's got all these powerful friends
he gets away with it the first time what
is what is the second time then how do
we understand that is it that just you
know you had an aggressive district
attorney in New York how exactly or a
day aggressive US attorney how exactly
does he get to get brought in the second
time um
so Maria said that it had to do with
some very tenacious NYPD detectives that
were very adamant about about you know
getting this guy charged again she said
the Berman guy Jeffrey Berman the
district attorney is not a good guy
that's what she said so that she said
that he basically had to act because
these guys at NYPD were like really
persistent and that she knew that he was
going to be arrested like two weeks
before because they had come to
interview her and like solidify up the
case and all this stuff and and these
NYPD guys how does the case even fall
into their lap I don't know personally
before I talk to her I put this had to
do with Deutsche Bank because it's just
two weeks before he was arrested a bank
which was the only bank that would still
really do business publicly anyway with
Epstein close their accounts do you
think there's anything true about the
idea that anthony Weiner's laptop had
information on it is this something that
you've heard this story that you've
heard this idea okay but i but it but
NYPD guys certainly pushed for Epstein
to be I guess that's what Maria said she
said they came to her what in June
okay of last year and and we're building
a case and that it was them not the
Berman guy and she said some of the
stuff that that Berman said during the
press conference she found really
offensive right but um I'd have to go
back in the call and find out exactly
what she said about it she named the
detective at NYPD that was like she said
was awesome but I can't recall his name
right well she was she after the assault
Epstein is then stalking her what does
that mean following her around
apparently they really didn't like it
when someone left and she had tried to
quit numerous times before and it was
always like no no you can go here you
can go there and they would try and pass
her pass her off to like you know
friends or whatever and I've been sure
that's how she ended up at wexner place
yeah and I guess it's intimidating when
you have all these powerful rich people
around you and you're working for them
you don't want to make enemies you try
to stick it out you know you and
annotate you know obviously once you're
assaulted then you're like okay it's
time to go you know I mean she didn't
realize like I said a lot of the things
that she had seen over the years that
she had just thought was weird and like
dismissed it just all sort of went
during the assault she said it all just
sort of started to click and like come
together and she was like oh that's what
these people really are not the do be
now have you you read it all about the
Dubin family you know Vanity Fair did an
article about that girlfriend daughter
was like yeah apparently this is kind of
common with these families that are tied
to this did you hear that thing about
did you see the thing about Bloomberg
goes wherever I am in the world I get my
daughter a date you see China yeah
they're kids this way it's sad I mean I
messed up in the head well neither did I
but I'm not [ __ ] kidnapping kids
outside of schools you know you can
overeat you can do drugs those are what
that's what how I've dealt with it this
episode of the Tim Dylan show is brought
to you by blue - guys remember the days
when you're always ready to go when you
had a big hard dick now you can increase
your performance to get that extra
confidence and bad list
up blue shoe calm that's blue like the
color blue dummy what did you lose
oxygen to the brain at birth are you a
dumb-dumb are you an aggressive beast of
a person that can't really read can't
organize your thoughts you just sent
there panting and sweating trying to
remember what the laws are you can't
just grab people and bite them that's
who this is for that's where we got to
tell you the color is B lue blue qu not
Blue's Clues brew-choo brings you the
first chewable with the same
fda-approved ingredients as viagra
cialis I don't think we're allowed to
say that bad okay great now leave it in
people like people like the authenticity
take them get a big dick full stomach
empty stomach they're they're chewy Bowl
they work up to twice as fast as a pill
she can be ready whenever an opportunity
arises and you know when an opportunity
arises whatever you say it does I'm
kidding that's not real aah
make sure you have consent you ask the
person if they would like to see your
penis do you want to see my beanie blue
troops prescribed online by licensed
physicians Nelson from The Simpsons
laughs oh I wish I could do that better
but huh you know blue cheese prescribes
online by licensed physicians oh so you
don't have to go to the doctor's office
or wait in line at the pharmacy it
shifts right to your door or your
mother's door in a discrete package
they're made in the USA we're making
dick pills not an one it not masks n95
masks or whatever the hell we don't make
them we don't make any antibiotics but
if you need a hard [ __ ] we make it right
here in the USA we don't farm that out
baby
the trichomes aren't doing that that's
us we can get your dick woke up so
that's blue2 Kombi lue CH e w compro
Makoti IM try it free what so now what
exactly does where is ghilane now what's
she up to what is she gonna come out and
reveal herself publicly she's suing
Epstein's estate cuz she wants her money
or something there's a law yeah
I think that's about giving the money
back for the intelligence agency that
funded this whole thing back to where it
came from right because why else would
she be suing because I mean her money
didn't come you know it was all given to
her do you think just like all of
Epstein's money we've given to him you
cannot make like billions he was given
all this money by thwack sir do you
think we'll see ghilane Maxwell again
ever publicly I don't know she is not
hiding in Israel that she's living in
the Rothschild mansion where's that was
her watch okay apparently they have
several yeah but that she's with the UK
Rothschilds on the head of that family
by the way Lord Jacob Rothschild since
we mentioned her earlier Marina
Abramovic
they have recently this picture of them
together and behind this painting that's
called like Satan summons his legions
they're like posing in this together
right I mean it's weird some weird sums
up why I was looking and again I was
always the skeptic a pizza gate only
because there were no victims right you
know Franklin victims can Cora victims
come forward North Fox Island victims
come forward Jeffrey Epstein victims
come forward in anything without victims
where we're just looking at our tour
which is but if you look at some of the
art that Tony Podesta had and some of
the artists and some of the artists that
he would frequently purchase art from
it's [ __ ] weird there's kids in cages
there they're tuned sacrifices it's very
odd you know I don't know man I've never
seen and I've been to some wealthy
people's homes I've really never seen
art like that right yeah you know a lot
of people like Wexner and like Epstein
before this started to come out I mean
their public persona I mean Bill Clinton
and the like caught in the early 2000s
called Epstein a philanthropist right I
mean they had like these rosy
reputations like look at how much
Webster is given the Ohio State
University and the medical schools named
after him and oh he gave all this money
to a hospital look at him giving all his
money away and people say the same stuff
about people like Bill Gates yeah
Bill Gates after the Epstein
skip hanging out with Epstein he knew
Epstein apparently in the 90s but he did
business together I don't know what that
business was but but Gates flew on his
plane like three times he went to the
island now get all this stuff that's
apparently fine that's apparently fine
I've seen all these different scientists
around him he said his interest was
eugenics what I mean what in in what
form what are they trying to do if you
had to wrap your head around why he's
having these salons with all these
scientists and he's having these you
know you know meetings with all these
important people in the field of science
what what is the goal what do you think
the end goal if you had to speculate I
know you don't love doing that because
you're a great reporter but if you had
to speculate what do you think he wants
does he want to influence health policy
so that it kind of promotes some of
these more nefarious ideas that he has
and does he want to rank you chantix up
in like a nice bow and say here it's not
eugenics it's uh whatever you know
whatever you would call it it's it's
better life we call it better life you
know right exactly what Bill Gates wants
but I do know what Jeffrey Epstein was
interested in in terms of his eugenics
interest and this has been reported in
mainstream media but if that's the case
with like what they did to Murray a
farmer and they only reported 5%
I mean Riley who knows but what they did
say is that he was basically interested
in essentially making like a master race
and that they were looking for girls
that were intelligent and and they were
asking about grades you know they only
wanted smart kids creative kids talented
kids and actually Maria farmers younger
sister was one of these girls that was
going to be that was being groomed to
have Epstein's children in glee and then
after the assault you know she got you
know Killeen called her and said you
ruined everything like she was gonna
have your sister was gonna have
Epstein's baby she was so lucky and all
this stuff like they really think their
genetics are superior um as far as what
Bill Gates might be up to I would you
know I don't want to speculate because I
don't um I don't know what he says in
private
I can't assume but I would really urge
people to look at the history of
eugenics in the United States because in
the 1920s the eugenics movement was so
powerful to the Supreme Court ruled that
a mother and her young daughter had to
be sterilized because they were too
stupid really were from like a poor yeah
oh yeah and and this is not isolated
there were states that had passed
eugenic laws before this I mean they're
the billionaires of the Gilded Age we're
really into this and and they were like
and the lady that they said to sterilize
and that Supreme Court ruling was a poor
white person you know they were just
like oh you're too stupid cuz you're
from you know the Appalachian Mountains
you know but they you know they've been
like that with other you know it's not
just white people you know of corn no of
course not obviously of course but that
type of mentality actually ended up
inspiring Hitler but obviously with
World War two that type of mentality
went out of style and there's a lot of
people who make the convincing argument
that those people that were a Genesis in
the United States during that period of
time maintained their views but found a
way to sort of let it slide under the
public right right controversial gadget
singer go there okay well Margaret
Sanger who was the founder of like
Planned Parenthood right a long time ago
she wrote very disturbing things about
African Americans right right
intentionally wanted to Planned
Parenthood centers there where there was
the highest concentration of
african-americans yeah I mean it's a bit
messy you can read her letter Oh God
you know I don't want to get into the
whole like issue because it's like such
a left and right divide and I really try
and do everything I can to like
transcend to the left-right divide
because there's so much more important
stuff anyways reading abortion ring
right but I mean if this lady was saying
this stuff and saying I want to put the
center here because I don't want this
particular race to like I don't want
there you know I don't want them to have
a lot of kids Wow yeah that's my stop in
Pete's father was associated with that
organization apparently he was he had
ties to the Rockefellers and the
Rockefeller family were from the time of
the first billionaire JD rockefeller in
the Gilded Age where they were passing
all these laws he was into that stuff
and his sons were into that stuff right
right so I would say to people that want
to sort of look at this look at the
history because we know what those
people were saying and what they were
doing because they were open about it
then right right and now they can ask
yourself yeah this continued they were
never held it held accountable you know
what I mean yeah it's very possible and
if you look at stuff Bill Gates has said
like you know a couple years ago too
many Africans right so now those those
those views have maybe gone underground
but they're still very much you know
held by people and what do you think it
is you know you study these people
you've written about them is it is it
power as it control do they want to just
control the entire world what's the goal
here what's the the end game is to just
have a slave race of people that will do
the jobs and then have this you know
kind of perfected race of people that
gets to enjoy the benefits of I mean
what what what do you think the picture
looks like well because you know like
you saying this had gone like
underground I really believe that
because something that Maria told me is
that she heard ghilane and all of these
people she was around say the most
racist things and I mentioned earlier
that they were very supremacist but they
would not go to cities where they
thought there were too many
african-americans they said racist first
of all I want about be SPEA I want my
human traffickers to be woke and
politically correct I do
I won't I don't sleep at night if my
human traffickers are not for diversity
and inclusion but bill is so Colleen
Maxwell I mean it's just fascinating to
me man when you when you look at all
this stuff how evil these people are how
powerful they are how big the system is
how utterly impossible it seems to get
any justice nobody seems to be able to
even what it looks like now who whacked
Epstein in your estimation Mossad hit
what is it
I honestly don't know because you know a
lot of people talk spend a lot of time
talking about his death and like what
happened to him I think that attention
is better spent asking how the heck are
we gonna get d'Alene Maxwell in prison
and how are we gonna get Leslie Wexner
in prison well or problem yeah I wish we
would there's no camera footage so
honestly anything could have happened
honestly I mean who really knows I mean
the prison guards won't talk they're
being charged I mean they won't say
anything right they were apparently like
a sleep or whatever right now in the
camera footage was there and then it
disappeared and who knows so you know I
don't really know what happened honestly
there's a lot of people that definitely
wanted him dead that's pretty clear he
was middle management
he brought we're saving if they killed
Robert Maxwell is usefulness you know
what I mean
coronavirus man-made natural what do you
think everyone that's saying they know
what it is I don't think they're telling
the truth because it's really hard to
know there's so much information out
there it's hard but what I do think is
inaccurate and we're seeing this huge
very similar to the weapons of mass
destruction so let's go to war with
China tomorrow yeah let's go to war with
China tomorrow yeah yeah yeah well
what's disturbing is that a lot of the
evidence these people are citing saying
it's a Chinese by a weapon for example
they cite studies and if you actually
look at those studies and you look at
the funding it was funded by not just
the Chinese government but a lot of US
government organizations and that that
lab in Wuhan had direct ties to Fort
Dietrich right and these other these
other you know u.s. research
organizations even these people that are
claiming that its exclusive Chinese
bioweapon they shared all these articles
today saying Facebook's factor what
worked at the Wuhan lab it's an American
right right and they're acting like
people aren't gonna get it you know I
mean so obviously there's like why would
they leave that out you know what do you
say there's something you think these
shutdowns continue do you think we can
ever get our rights back do you think
that they're gonna keep finding ways to
take more and more rights under the
guise of yeah yeah now public health
it was terrorism for many years now
it'll now it'll be public health yeah
well it's another invisible enemy isn't
it other where the you know the
terrorists and after 9/11 and now you
know we're allied the US government is
like allied with al Qaeda in Syria and
Yemen basically like fighting some
there's a half a Miss and we gave up all
those all these rights for that yeah
friendly supporting them I mean it's
insane
but in terms of coronavirus I'm some of
the reporting I've done in recent weeks
has really shown that a lot of the
solutions for coronavirus that were
being told we need to you know these
systems like these surveillance systems
we have to implement you know these were
planned out last year months ago yeah um
for example this coronavirus
surveillance system they were promoting
this under a different name called safe
home under this agency they wanted to
make called harpa it was Ivanka Trump
promoting that now Jared Kushner is
promoting this thing today in his like
new task force or whatever but last year
they were saying it needed to be done to
stop mass shootings and what what is
what they're doing what is taking these
solutions that they want to implement
and they're just tacking on whatever
Americans are most afraid of what is
this yeah now it's perilla fire what is
this surveillance system though what are
they trying to do what are they gonna
try to do well they're basically trying
to get Americans private medical records
in a giant database mixed with
everything that's on your consumer
smartphone and use it to make sure
you're not social distancing and all
this stuff but it's definitely more than
that and I'll tell you why because last
October bill Barr the Attorney General
created a pre-crime program that started
this year it's called deep the
disruption and early engagement program
he created that last year saying that
this was supposed to be to stop mass
shootings and it's it's pre-crime
because the idea behind it is that you
arrest someone who's mobilizing towards
violence and the way you do it is by
looking at their health records and what
they say on social media and that you
arrest them before they can they can
strike right that's pre-crime and that
is a slippery slope and under after
coronavirus and although all these
lockdowns happens bill barge Department
of Justice asked for the right to
indefinitely detain Americans without
trial he hasn't gotten the
but he might think that this poll
surveillance dragnet they're not going
to be pushing through it's crazy I have
another report coming out next week
about this little-known US government
body called the National Security
Commission on artificial intelligence
it's chaired by Eric Schmidt formerly
the head of you know alphabet Google's
parent company and is full of all these
like CIA guys Pentagon guys and
basically what they say in this document
that just came out last year that no one
is reporting on which is insane they
basically say in order for the u.s. as a
you know uh for national security
purposes we have to maintain a technical
article advantage over China and
artificial intelligence and the way to
do that is to remake American society so
that we adopt a Chinese style like
surveillance state but worse than what
China has that's basically what he said
was scandalous where is this coming out
of again I'll send it to you it came out
of a Freedom of Information Act request
I'm just like a couple days ago no one's
covered it and it is just the most
scandalous document and it's insane and
they're told is the opposite of you're
hearing about you know oh the social
credit score and Oh China is abusing
human rights they are literally saying
we have to do that here or we will not
be able to set international norms and
not be able to like control the market
of the fourth Industrial Revolution that
AI is going to create and all this stuff
and you're basically saying we have to
eliminate individual car ownership we
have to eliminate cash and credit cards
you can't even see like they call these
things legacy systems
oh no that's basically in there feels
like no more in-person shopping you have
to do it online now and yeah is you this
is so [ __ ] nuts because this is not
what I was talking about in the band
these are people that are said in order
to be China we have to become China yeah
that's what they're saying they're
saying China is going to leapfrog us and
go miles ahead and adoption of these
technologies unless we D do what they're
doing and we do it faster and we have to
leap frog then basically and do you and
they're basically using this pandemic to
do that to remake society they're doing
this controlled demolition of the
economy
and they're not gonna reopen it up until
they remake everything I think wow based
on the stuff this is this is very
disturbing so they want to get rid of a
lot of these legacy systems that's what
they call it
yeah like going to a store in person and
buying stuff legacy system yeah
owning your own car legacy system using
cash or a credit card legacy system so
now what are you gonna use they want it
to be all smartphone based payments like
they do in India now because India like
a year or two ago like a lemony that
almost all currency in circulation and
no one there has credit cards so they
all had to adopt this like um like
mobile wallet like digital wallet which
is really similar to the stuff they put
out in that coronavirus relief bill the
digital dollar and all the stuff that
they were like sort of putting in there
yeah what we mean is always in that
reading you know what was in that bill
what were they what are they doing what
are they building in there what are they
doing in that field well I considering
at the time they passed it after the
crisis was like you know exploding they
had that prepared well in advance right
but those kind of types of bills just
like the Patriot Act they just don't
they don't write them like in a couple
days and say here sign I mean raid on
9/11 the Patriot Act was ready to go and
I think this bill is the same and like I
said all these people last year we're
like making these plans and they were
simulating pandemics to Crimson
contagion that was a nineteen federal
agency twelve states a bunch of private
companies and gaming out a pandemic in
the u.s. four times last year from
January to August and they had one day
on the last exercise or the last
simulation which was like lasted four
days the entire third day was the
secretary of the Treasury and Finance
and I think that's where that bill came
from what is so they want everything
like China on your smart phone they want
everything you know they want to
everything basically I don't even want
people to have laptops they want all on
the phone why why not laptops are they
harder to trace oh yeah nobody knows I
guess I just want everyone's life on the
phone
pretty much where it's going they're
like phase all the stuff out and make it
all the phone all the phone is crazy I
will send you this yeah yeah I don't
believe you're making all the stuff like
mass surveillance is awesome it's a
killer way to Train artificial
intelligence they say it's awesome that
in China people are using the police use
voice recognition technology to arrest
people before they commit crimes bleh
boy oh boy before they commit crimes and
this commission is supposed to give the
recommendations to the government about
how from this national security point of
view how to maintain an advantage over
China and this is what they're saying
and someone had to do this Freedom of
Information Act request to get it and
this is like the only document produced
by that body they got and like I said
this is headed by the ex-google guy Eric
Schmidt but it's it has like two
different like the first CEO of in-q-tel
the CIA's venture capital arm right yeah
it has the current CEO of in-q-tel and
has the former Deputy Director of
National Intelligence I mean it is just
it's spooks and it's Amazon it's
Microsoft Google it's Oracle Oracle by
the way is involved in the corona virus
response right now I'm like reopening
the economy with Trump I mean all of
these same players that are on this
Commission are also involved in this
reopening the economy business and what
do you think they're gonna do probably
what they were saying in private last
year you know what I mean
so this is really terrifying this is
like ending freedom whatever what little
freedoms we have left getting rid of
them now why not why no private
ownership of vehicles what is what is
behind that is that the climate-related
they just don't wait no no they want
economy like autonomous self-driving
fleets of like ride-sharing cars they
say that like things like uber and all
this stuff that that's where this has to
go that individual car ownership is like
dangerous and that it needs to be fleet
ownership it's more efficient and all
this stuff I mean that's basically what
about and they say if we don't do it in
China will be better at it than what in
the sport it to other countries in our
giant Silicon Valley tech
pennies will lose money if we don't put
a chip in your arm China is gonna put
chips and everybody's arm and they're
gonna make the money
exactly [ __ ] yeah yeah what about home
ownership is there anything in the
document about that no not specifically
it's redacted they didn't include all
the slides so there's a lot on that
there's a lot in that document that they
left out Oh documents tons of meetings
and briefings and all this stuff and
this is the only thing they put out yeah
one little document trickled out and
this is these are all the guys from
Google so these are and this is what I
was talking to Joe about this is what I
say a lot of these people have pretty
[ __ ] scary ideas that are hidden from
public view and by the time you know
what they are they've already been been
been foisted on you and you yeah you
know you can't get away from them Wow
that's why it's important to like bring
this out I will send this over I mean
like well hopefully you won't share it
before my reports up so I don't know
we'll wait you do your thing people this
will come out Sunday in two days and the
people will listen to us talk about it
everybody will read your article I mean
all of this is mind-blowing all of it is
crazy I you know I really feel like
they're using the lockdown to do a bunch
of stuff they normally couldn't get away
with and I think that's why this ruling
about Epstein and the sweetheart be all
happened now - right right Elaina
Maxwell election off what are people
gonna do and then the corporate relief
the relief bill or whatever was a four
times bigger bailout for Wall Street
than 2008 and after the 2008 bailouts
there was occupied Wall Street there
were protests but everyone's on lockdown
what are they gonna do right the yellow
vests protest Express $200 check the LMS
in France ten weeks yeah yeah yeah
that's done well the Hong Kong protests
are done right actually a lot of the
first countries to do de lockdowns
actually all have protest movements
going on it's like so Fran said the
yellow vests Spain had
the separatists in Catalonia Chile where
I live had a lot of protests that begin
last October that we're trying to get
the current President of Chile to resign
those went away and he the President of
Chile say West yunpeng Guerra he
declared a constitution late like
suspended the Constitution for 90 days
and declared a lockdown before there was
a single death in Chile
he was like damn let's go mm-hmm did
they give a timeframe with any of these
things that they want to do in that
document that trickled out or we don't
know it doesn't it doesn't give a
timeframe but considering that you know
they're like we got to act now or China
will you know take it over it just
really shows that all this rhetoric
about like China bad America good that's
not what they really think what they
really think is like we like the Chinese
model right it needs to be us doing it
and wrong sporting it and then we'll be
the global hegemony forever yeah we
don't do it and people gonna be led into
the slaughterhouse because we've created
this fake us first China and we're gonna
become China supposedly in order to beat
China great yeah well not great but you
know what it is it doesn't make any
sense I mean it's just the most
illogical thing ever and that's why I
think it's so important because some
people will see like the lie and the
rhetoric you know yeah okay Oh China's a
huge threat to human rights and they're
hostile and they're going to expand well
which I'm sure they are I'm sure they
I'm sure they're not I'm sure they're
not doing anything great over in China
in terms of human rights oh but I like
the u.s. is being super good at critical
publicly yeah you know they're doing
like what what Clinton said I have a
public in a private position I mean
people yeah it's very true very
disturbing stuff Whitney Webb as always
work you were up at night now we were up
before but now we're up more tell people
where they can support you financially
any which way you are so essential
you're the only person really doing this
kind of work where can people read your
stuff where can they find you how could
they give you money um well I
Petrey on in January as to help finance
my
Epstein book because it's a small
publisher that was really gracious it
was um you know they also publish the
book on the Franklin scandal by Nick
Bryant so it's a good fit
but unfortunately cuz there's small they
really kind of give me much in terms of
an advance so a lot of stuff like
research help and things like that or
access to some you know online sources
and databases and stuff I have to pay
all of that out of pocket so if you'd
like to support that you can support me
on patreon I also have on some exclusive
yes your your tell them what your
patreon is where can they go you just
have to search for Whitney Webb but I
think it's Whitney Webb in PN 4 when I
used to work it at Christmas we'll put
it we'll put it in the description of
the YouTube and on the potty yeah well
we'll get in there yeah and you can
follow me on twitter under sport Whitney
Webb I'm also on mastodons and gab as
well which because I'm probably gonna
get kicked off of Twitter at some point
ok think do you think so uh I think the
D platform is coming yeah actually last
I think it was October September um all
these social media companies met with
intelligence in the US and they were
like you guys have to protect public
discourse ahead of the 2020 election and
they were like yeah well basically like
the platform you before next November so
I think it's probably coming yeah Wow
I mean I'd say that would be the least
of our problems if even half of what
we've just heard comes to fruition
you know sorry all my written work you
can read at the last American vagabond
calm that's also a YouTube channel um
the last American vagabond and I go on
there sometimes talk about my work and
it gets showcased there as well well
Whitney Webb you are really really
important you are what I would call an
essential worker I hope everybody goes
and supports you reads your stuff I mean
and what we'll always have Y on your
phenomenal thank you very much for
spending time with us and good luck and
be safe out there
yeah thanks alright thank you bye bye